hey everyone so big news that we just
heard today and that is that Aaron
taylor-johnson was reported to be on set
for Avengers 4 if you're not familiar
with who Aaron taylor-johnson is he is
the actor that plays Quicksilver before
we get started just a quick reminder
about our giveaway if you want to enter
to win a free speaker system all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
and the rest of the details are in
description below it's been rumored that
Quicksilver will be in Avengers 4 and
this pretty much confirms it for us
however we're not exactly sure how he'll
be in Avengers 4 there are of course
several ways he could come back
especially since Avengers 4 is very
heavily rumored to be a time travel
movie with it being a time travel movie
then there are many ways that you can go
from here one is that the Avengers
somehow get their hands on the Infinity
Gauntlet if they get their hands on the
Infinity Gauntlet they can pretty much
do whatever they want and since
Quicksilver is the brother of the
Scarlet Witch it'd be pretty easy for
her to say hey let's bring back my
brother since you know you dad
so that's one way with the Infinity
Gauntlet another way is they could only
get their hands on the time stone
obviously with them having the time
stone they could somehow figure out a
way to bring Quicksilver back that way
and then there's the way that I think is
most likely to happen and that is some
of the Avengers will go back in time
using Pym technology if you're not
familiar with Pym technology dr. Henry
Hank Pym is the creator of the ant-man
suit he's a physicist and it is heavily
rumored that ant-man and the wasp will
really explore the quantum realm in the
movie so I think that during ant-man and
the wasps dr. Pym will somehow figure
out time travel or if not in the movie
definitely after he may have some help
from Tony Stark but either way I thank
him Tony Stark Captain America and the
Hulk go back in time based on some
leaked Avengers force set photos that
we've seen so there's a few ways that he
could come back I mean it's the MCU so
there are obviously many crazy things
that can happen in many ways that he
could come back but here just a few and
it's been said that Aaron taylor-johnson
has signed a three movie contract and
he's only done one now this obviously
happens in Hollywood actor signed
contracts and for whatever reason in
depth not going through
with all the movies they signed up for
but fans were pretty disappointed that
Quicksilver died so easily and the fans
really liked him and the fact that he
has been seen on set really confirms to
us that he'll in fact be making an
appearance again in Avengers 4 unless
this is just the Russo brothers trolling
us again which is very possible but I
personally hopes that he makes an
appearance and Avengers 4 and comes back
in whatever way they choose well that's
it for this video I hope you enjoyed it
if you did please hit that thumbs up
button and if you'd like to stay
up-to-date on Avengers 4 news and just
enjoy Marvel another superhero videos
subscribe to my channel and again the
details for the giveaway are in the
description below thank you so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]